[Musica]
da dieci anni quindi circa abbiamo
avviato questa pratica nelle dolomiti
che sapete dal 2009 sono patrimonio
dell'umanità bene unesco
quindi nel 2009 l'uomo ha stabilito il
valore e lo status di questo bene per
l'eccezionale valore universale per la
qualità estetica e paesaggistica bene su
questo lavoriamo noi sulla definizione
del concetto di patrimonio e di
paesaggio le dolomiti sono patrimonio
abbiamo definito con questa parola e il
loro valore
però noi viviamo nelle lo miti e alle
mie spalle vedete andare alle immagini
dei siti di cui ci occupiamo da dieci
anni a questa parte sono siti molto
importanti nella storia e nella
costruzione dell'identità dei territori
e dei paesaggi paesaggi diciamo non
preesistono all'uomo
l'uomo deve farli deve contribuire a con
generarli questi stabilimenti che vedete
sono ex fabbriche stabilimenti
produttivi o ex scuole ex colonie alpine
tutti diciamo city ecco introdotti da
questa particella this missiva ex perché
non sono più sono stati sono stati
vettori trattori del territorio al loro
interno si è lavorato si è costruito
reddito economia socialità cultura
e poi ci sono fermati ora voi li vedete
in una diciamo terza fase
la prima fase è stata quella della loro
edificazione da parte dell'uomo che li
ha costruiti in seno al paesaggio e al
flusso della storia dalla seconda fase
quella dismessi va fine della loro vita
produttiva e propulsiva all'interno del
paesaggio per il territorio
la terza fase è questa
perché vi dicevo da dieci anni
affrontiamo questi nodi irrisolti
critici e problematici del paesaggio
ovvero questi grandi siti che hanno
posseduto un valore molto rilevante e
poi l'hanno perso
hanno perso la propria primigenia
identità
la terza fase quella del risveglio
bisogna capire se siamo in grado di
ripensarne un uso funzionale se possono
tornare ad essere utili al territorio
oppure se non esistono più perché sono
vestigia sappiamo tutto di loro nel
passato sappiamo poco di loro nel
presente perché tendenzialmente non si è
più riusciti ad agili e quindi non
possiamo immaginare il loro futuro
cosa sono quindi dei cimiteri che noi
contempliamo guardando al passato retro
versi oppure sono effettivamente
patrimonio cioè bene c'è potenziale
rigenerabile bene questo è stata la
nostra scommessa
a due anni dal raggiungimento di quello
status abbiamo iniziato a indagare
questi siti che sono molti
le dolomiti se non è sicuramente il
patrimonio ma sono anche un patrimonio
di stereotipi per certi aspetti di
cliché idee piuttosto banali attraverso
le quali si vede una montagna che o non
c'è più
era quella del nonno con le braghe alla
zuava oppure è sempre una montagna che
fatica molto a guardare avanti a
traguardare nuovi orizzonti perché è già
data ma stiamo dicendo che i paesaggi
vanno generati dall uomo rigenerati non
sono dati per sempre alle volte sono
dati solo per un periodo bene nelle
prime fabbriche nelle prime immagini che
avete visto che abbiamo affrontato nei
primi due anni è caduto questo giacevano
dopo aver funzionato per il territorio e
poi qualcuno ha provato a muoverle sono
arrivati degli enti tendenzialmente
pubblici o anche privati e cosa hanno
fatto un restauro e cosa è successo dopo
restauro che sono rimasti fermi come
prima del restauro
cosa vuol dire questo che sono arrivate
le risorse economiche ma non sono
arrivate le risorse vere
in questo modo il patrimonio è stato
tradito perché era deficitario il
corredo di risorsa che si tentava di
applicare per risvegliare il bene e cosa
mancava un idea perché se ti limiti a
restaurare un bene ma non è l'idea di
cosa che vorrei fare lo tradì rai e
farai un male che tra l'altro è costato
molto bene con un progetto culturale ma
con una logica funzionale perché il test
è anche quello di verificare se la
cultura sia un apparato didascalico o
diciamo esornativo oppure se possa
essere un attivatore reale concreto è un
driver una parte della co progettazione
dei paesaggi e dei territori abbiamo
affrontato questi siti
avete capito erano finiti ma non sfiniti
a nostro giudizio è sicuramente c'era
una grande potenzialità in questi siti
c'è cos'è questa potenzialità
considerate che come state vedendo sono
straordinari per valori estetici propri
per il loro contesto
poi sicuramente sono fermi e forse la
cosa che importa di più è che devi
selezionare quelli giusti non tutti i
siti sono suscettibili di essere
rigenerati di tornare utili devono avere
una consistenza logistica per usare
questa parola pratica e quindi ci deve
essere un idea funzionale nell'approccio
e nel tentativo di rigenerarli cioè
alcuni siti è meglio non affrontarli
diciamo che bisogna soppesarle
correttamente altri se valgono davvero
molto impotenza e niente della realtà
nella realtà è opportuno e necessario
affrontarle è una questione di
responsabilità e poi anche di
sostenibilità
vedremo bene i siti di cui ci occupiamo
sono solo alcuni non tutti non è
l'archeologia industriale è una
selezione ristretta ma ampia abbiamo
lavorato su una ventina di siti da dal
2011 ad oggi di siti appunto che valgono
sicuramente moltissimo ma nulla nella
realtà quindi c'è una ampia misura da
colmare perché se un sito diciamo tutti
che vale molto
vale 100 qui siamo nell'ex villaggio eni
di borca di cadore che fece il signor
enrico mattei negli anni 50 con l'a
rchitetto edoardo gellner e anche
insieme a carlo scarpa in una parte se
diciamo che vale molto ma non vale
niente nella realtà vuol dire che noi
non riusciamo mai a risvegliare il
potenziale di questo sito
e a cosa serve il suo potenziale al
legittimo proprietario
no tutti i siti hanno un legittimo
proprietario pubblico e privato o
privato ma come state vedendo ora state
vedendo il forte di montericco a pieve
di cadore poi rivedrete il vajont i siti
che scegliamo sono talmente forti
formidabili ed eccezionali da essere o
esemplificativi di temi più vasti di
loro stesso ho veramente diciamo bisogna
essere ciechi per non vederne il
potenziale allora il loro valore di
patrimonio è di tutti non solo dell'ente
che ne possiede la fisicità e su questo
lavoriamo noi con un progetto di
responsabilità e riuso lavoriamo a
riprendere il valore patrimoniale in
senso culturale di questo bene per tutti
cosa possano tornare ad essere questi
siti dipende nei primi casi delle
fabbriche che avete visto nelle prime
immagini sono tornati essere fabbriche
cosa abbiamo fatto e abbiamo approcciati
erano falliti abbiamo costruito una
serie di relazioni
abbiamo quasi 500 partner chi sono
questi palmer se non parlano
territoriali ed extraterritoriali
pubblici e privati imprese aziende
partner scientifici o della ricerca
in sostanza si compie un grande momento
di attivazione di reti territoriali ed
extra territoriali e si cerca di far di
nuovo vedere la pila il potenziale dei
siti è un po come avere un gran cesto di
frutta eccezionale in cucina ma la luce
spenta nessuno mangia la frutta che va
male è sufficiente accendere la luce non
è facile accendere la luce in un sito
che è fermo da anni o decenni dove
diciamo la società
di colore in quel contesto peculiare ha
perso speranza tutti la perderebbero
prima funzionava
poi non ha funzionato più poi l'abbiamo
restaurato e ancora non è andato è un
maledetto inghiottitoio no è una risorsa
che bisogna rimettere in rete come fai a
metterla in rete
se non accendendo le reti prima si
parlava di dopamina ricordate questa
mattina c'è un saggio del 74 mi sembra
di un neuropsichiatra oliver sacks
si intitola awakening il risveglio si
parla di malattia letargia e di cura io
sono un curatore romiti contemporanea un
progetto di cura e di curatela del
paesaggio del patrimonio
serve la dopamina culturale serve
un'iniezione serve una neurotrasmissione
serve insufflare la fiducia nei
territori che l'hanno persa per
riaccendere loro stessi questi siti
appartengono a questo territorio che li
contiene ma poi sono talmente importanti
vedete il vajont che esubera no
ampiamente la propria collocazione
geografica in seno al territorio
il punto è che sono esclusi dal flusso
della storia sapete cosa è successo nel
vajont e 9 ottobre del 63
non sono morte 2 mila persone sono morti
un po tutti gli uomini della terra
quindi quel luogo è lì e non è lì è di
tutti gli uomini della terra è un luogo
emblematico è al tempo stesso un luogo
particolare collocato in un punto dello
spazio tempo e un luogo universale per
cui riaccendere la scuola la vecchia
scuola elementare chiusa dal vajont e
farne un centro per la cultura
contemporanea della montagna del
paesaggio vuol dire affrontare un sito
spento terribilmente spento perché il
vajont per certi aspetti è la terra dei
morti viventi è un luogo dove c'è una
diga che richiama ogni anno migliaia e
miglia
le migliaia di persone che
tendenzialmente vedono una lapide un
muro del pianto affrontare questo
paesaggio non volendo ammettere il fatto
che esso possa coincidere con il
paesaggio della tragedia
questo vuol dire tradire gli uomini i
paesaggi sono per i vivi che li devono
costruire c'è una definizione di edoardo
gellner il realizzatore dell'ex
villaggio eni cioè del programma sociale
di welfare
ieri con mattei e di molte altre cose
che il nel dice che il paesaggio è la
sommatoria di ambiente naturale azione
dell'uomo buona azione buon paesaggio
attivazione pessimo paesaggio non un
luogo per l'uomo
dunque il vajont non può essere un
paesaggio dimenticato retroverso
ostaggio di una tragedia che c'è stata e
non c'è più o paralizzato nella memoria
che può essere anche un patogeno perché
non consente se non la elabori di
prefigurare paesaggio altro paesaggio
paesaggio proiettivo nel vajont e
necessaria una situazione proiettiva per
cui se venite a vedere cos'è il nuovo
spazio di cassa è un presidio culturale
che si oppone alla predatoria egemonia
di una tragedia che non può essere
l'identità dei vivi di oggi non c'è
dimenticarsi non c'è assenza di memoria
c'è una visione che vuole restituire
questi siti agli uomini che sono coloro
che li hanno fatti poi li hanno persi
bene tutto ciò si fa come vi sto dicendo
in ogni sito si realizza una residenza
vengono artisti vengono anche architetti
designer paesaggisti economisti la
cultura scienziati filosofi viene marco
g che abbiamo portato nel vajont come a
borca di cadore a riflettere su questi
luoghi
altro che non luoghi ma siamo in grado
di ri proiettarli nel presente in modo
utile o no si credono nel momento in cui
riusciamo non a suggestionare una platea
ma convincere il territorio che quella è
roba sua
che può tornare ad essere utile nel
vajont bisogna vivere
l'ex villaggio eni di borca di cadore
può servire a molte cose non serve a se
stesso questi siti non bastano loro
stessi non c'entra quanto belli o
importanti sono stati non bastano serve
un'azione vigorosa dell'uomo e
deliberata l'azione a noi nessuno ci ha
obbligati io lavoro con una trentina di
ragazzi giovani del territorio che
vogliono fare qualcosa per il territorio
e quindi affrontiamo i siti attraverso
le strategie delle reti attiviamo
territorio di cui siamo il reattore
diciamo convinciamo territorio a
riprendere fiducia in un'impresa del
rilancio
per questo abbiamo 500 partner dal
territorio me da fuori il territorio ce
ne sono molti di internazionali molti di
nazionali molti di locali grandi e
piccoli tutti indispensabili anche
perché noi non abbiamo i soldi
vi ricordate prima erano venuti i soldi
senza le idee non era patrimonio non era
risorse poi arriviamo noi senza i soldi
ma con un patrimonio di idee e i siti
ripartono i primi siti sono ripartiti
sono entrate attività commerciali e
produttive perché hanno riscoperto la
logistica intelligente di quei siti non
erano affatto morti alcuni siti sono più
importanti di altri perché pesano di più
nel volume fisico storico del valore
estetico e così via come l'ex villaggio
eni dove torniamo tra poco li si
attivano piattaforme più strutturali
come nel vajont non vai a riaprire una
fabbrica nel vajont
abbiamo dovuto vivere due anni nel
vajont e farci capire dagli abitanti
potevamo essere gli ultimi stupidi o
cannibali
invece no per quello che ho detto prima
alla giornata ragioniamo in una logica
di funzionalità pubblica non privata ma
ci sono egoisti dei curatori o degli
artisti tutti concorrono e fanno un
pezzo del programma di rilancio
ma questo non tradisce l'arte che è
sempre se stessa solo che l'artista è un
intelligente sensibile
ingegnoso e un enzima attiva processi
non si accontenta di definizioni né di
sentenze per cui per lui il sito non è
morto
contribuisce a rigenerarlo i siti
diventano cantieri della produzione
artistica e culturale dove si innescano
le reti anche perché partiamo le genti
molto diverse tra loro ci sono gli
scienziati della foresta sapete cosa
tempesta vai a 14 milioni di alberi
portati giù dal vento ottobre 2018
se venite nei siti che state vedendo in
particolare a caso dal forte di
montericco trovate delle mostre
collettive d'arte contemporanea con
trenta artisti che lavorano su temi di
vaia insieme a scienziati del clima
della foresta biologi chimici quindi
l'arte non fa una cabrio letta non è
l'apparato esornativo e parte del
meccanismo della strategia di
rigenerazione i siti ripartono dunque e
li mettiamo anche nelle piattaforme a
disposizione tornando a borca sapete che
da un po di tempo ci siamo guadagnati le
olimpiadi del 2020 6 milano cortina si
dice che hanno da essere sostenibili
sono sostenibili se non costruisci
dell'architettura nuova e ti sai
responsabilmente render conto di cosa
c'è già a disposizione mille giovani di
borca sono 100mila metri quadri
costruiti molto bene perché c'erano
mattei e gellner non c'erano limiti di
spesa ma soprattutto di ingegno
quello è uno spazio su cui dobbiamo
spendere considerazioni serie lo
riprendiamo no è fatto talmente bene che
non è un rudere è vicino a cortina
non è una logica antagonista borca o
cortina le olimpiadi d'altro canto non
sono le gare di sci del 2026 sono
un'opportunità di sviluppo per il
territorio da cui ali e quindi occorre
ancora prendere il patrimonio per
inserirlo e rifilarlo e anche se diciamo
sostenibilità e basso consumo di suolo
vedere quel che c'è prima di fare del
nuovo è semplice diceva una cosa del
signor mattei diceva che l'ingegno anche
accomuna gli scienziati e gli artisti
la capacità di vedere cose dove non le
vedono gli altri occorre essere orbi per
non vedere il potenziale di questi siti
credo io quindi non basta vederle in
effetti mattei non si limitava a vedere
faceva molto allora se questi siti
valgono davvero molto impotenza come
diciamo vanno visti e poi vanno fatti
dobbiamo costruire i paesaggi della
contemporaneità lo sguardo del
contemporaneo è questo non è nostalgico
o nel retro verso vi dicevo cerca di
proiettare i propri potenziali avanti
non immemore del dietro avanti questa è
una cosa che va considerata dobbiamo
capire se noi siamo effettivamente in
grado di risvegliarlo questo patrimonio
o se ci accontentiamo di dire che le
dolomiti sono patrimonio dell'umanità
senza poi entrare all'interno del
territorio vedere cosa possiamo davvero
fare con le nostre armi
la cultura le sensibilità l'intelligenza
per riattivare questi siti a favore di
tutti
[Applauso]
[Musica]